et bien nathalie avait raison c'était le
yaourt bien elle fait gagner l'équipe
des filles encore une fois alors pour
nous c'est le moment de nous quitter
mais juste avant bien sûr comme chaque
semaine nous allons nous divertir en
chansons alors à propos de films
m'indique oui que la rue botzaris les
buttes chaumont les portes cochères de
nos studios sont assaillis 1,2 gramme de
filles d'ailleurs si vous êtes chez vous
messieurs je vous conseille vivement
d'attaché vos femmes à vos canapés avec
un cadenas parce que les trois artistes
qui vont nous rejoindre sont des
séducteur en diable on le sait ils sont
frères amis ça n'est pas toujours le cas
et musiciens ils nous viennent de
bretagne ils ont 24 22 et 21 ans
il s'appelle yann erwan et loïc qu elle
est on les écoute
[Musique]
un seul sourit le
ça suffit
jamais
alala semble battre comme jamais
avantagé
le sang froid
je souhaite vrai
[Musique]
ton appel
le contrôle
comme son père
du temps sur moi
les tours de mon corps se resservent
je sens venir
je sens non
qui sait
salomé
à se câliner
obsédé
son sourire
m
[Musique]
ses yeux vous fait tourner la tête ils
montrent aussi
plus de place dans mon coeur personne
à lui sucer
je frôle la fin
face à l'enjeu
[Musique]
hu a sonné
elle sait ce que j'aime de vie
bakchich
[Musique]
m
avec ses yeux de biche
j
salomé
[Musique]
et
salomé
et bien bravo on peut saluer anne-marie
qu elle ait fait la maman de ces trois
charmants gaillard venus danser pour eux
à la semaine prochaine